[Musique]
oh
la base de fonds dès ce matin
elle va aussi si tu veux même pas
cardiaque
[Rires]
j'ai quand même eu trop d'excès pendant
35 minutes maxi della valle d'inventer
une histoire d'or une image de playboy
les beaux gosses marche comme ça
aux fans
ces goûts et aux familles auraient
dénoncé une faute à trouver l'équilibré
continuent d'écumer le pied gauche qui
termine la main droite de côté et si tu
chantes tu ton problème c'est dur comme
le tiercé défi plaquettes et bayal la
mousse j'ai vu gagna matelas gonflable
qui fait comme poulenc cette histoire la
météo il est vrai déjà fait non c'est
hip hop et chomo encline à qui j'ai
justement quelles sont en commande la
danse musique et sexué
ouais
[Musique]
ce soir comme ça